von Marseille nach Barcelona zu kommen
kann man natürlich fliegen aber man kann
so wie ich es ja gerne mache auch
einfach mit dem Zug fahren also bin ich
in der spanischen Grenzstadt Figueres
umgestiegen in den spanischen Ave
Hochgeschwindigkeitszug und von dort aus
nach Barcelona Gefahren viel Spaß mit
diesem zugtest Ende 2012 erreicht das
spanische schnellfahrtstrecknetz eine
Gesamtlänge von
2665 km und es damit das längste
höchstgeschwindigkeitsnetz der Welt
danach kommt China eigentlich echt krass
weil China ist sehr viel größer die
höchstgeschwindigkeitszüge werden von
Rente oder orange sorry wenn ich wieder
falsch es tut mir leid betrieben und
connecten über 10 spanische Großstädte
darunter Barcelona Madrid Sevilla
Valencia und so weiter die spanischen
höchstgeschwindigkeitszüge erreichen
dabei eine Geschwindigkeit von maximal
300 km/h und mehr habe ich jetzt im
Internet auch nicht gefunden was
irgendwie noch interessant sein könnte
deswegen starten wir direkt mal rein ich
befinde mich hier gerade auf der
Durchreise von Marcel bis nach Barcelona
ich war jetzt mein Tag in Marseille und
möchte mir jetzt noch Barcelona angucken
und wir sind hier gerade ziemlich an der
französisch-spanischen Grenze und ich
bin nicht geflogen sondern mit dem Zug
gefahren und von hier aus geht's jetzt
weiter im Ave spanischen Highspeed train
ausgeschrieben Alter Velo sidad espanol
ich habe natürlich wieder die erste
Klasse gebucht und ich freue mich ich
hoffe es wird spannend und entspannt das
kann man ja auch dazu sagen was ich euch
auf jeden Fall empfehlen kann wenn ihr
in Spanien reisen wollt ist die App
brennt das ist auch der Anbieter dieser
Züge und hier kann man die alle ganz
entspannt buchen spanien hat auch ein
echt super ausgebautes und sehr
pünktliches Hochgeschwindigkeitsnetz
Barcelona bis Madrid fährt man nur
zweieinhalb Stunden und das sind glaube
ich fast 500 km also echt gut
aufgehts valand viel Geres ja wollte
dann zu meinem Zug gehen und mir ist
aufgefallen dass ich das noch gar nicht
konnte weil das ist ein Spanien ziemlich
interessant und einzigartig bevor man
nämlich in ein Ave Zug einsteigen kann
muss man erstmal an jedem Bahnhof durch
Sonnen Security Check gehen ähnlich wie
am Flughafen nur nicht ganz so streng
und da wird aber dann trotzdem erstmal
dein ganzes Gepäck gecheckt und ja wenn
irgendwas dabei ist was nicht dabei sein
darf kannst du vielleicht zurückfahren
ich habe mich mal erkundigt und das ist
unter anderem auf die Zug
Terroranschläge vom 11 märz 2004 in
Madrid zurückzuführen da wurden in über
10 Zügen Bomben platziert und die soll
halt auch gesprengt gehabt ziemlich
viele Opfer ja und die dachten sich dann
halt Security Check ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so schlecht somit kann man
zwar erst 5 Minuten vor Zug Abfahrt auch
ans Gleis aber mich hat es jetzt nicht
sonderlich gestärkt Security checkst du
gerade bestanden das habe ich bis jetzt
erst einmal gemacht und das war beim
Eurostar also hier haben wir es auch an
jedem Bahnhof anscheinend in Spanien ist
ja in Deutschland z.B irgendwo so jetzt
geht's in Zug
die pünktlichkeitsrat hier ist übrigens
bei über
99%. ich muss wieder ganz nach vorne
erste Klasse ist für mich immer vorne
und ich glaube das ist tatsächlich auch
überall so Wagen eins Platz 11a und der
Zug fährt sogar durch Bus Madrid das
hier war dann also mein Zug und ich habe
mal ein bisschen recherchiert ich glaube
ich habe einen älteres Modell erwischt
ich bin jetzt kein Zug Experte deswegen
alle Experten unter euch die sich
Ausgang schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
so sehen nämlich nach meinen Recherchen
die neueren Züge aus die am alten
anderes Führerhaus sieht ein bisschen
abgeflippte aus und das Interieur ist
halt moderner
Platz
okay Leute ich bin drin ich glaube wenn
mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht habe ich
ein älteres Modell erwischt angekommen
im Zugabteil der ersten Klasse ich habe
mich erstmal entspannt hingesetzt und
mich dann auf Barcelona gefreut weil ich
war dann noch nie und so ein bisschen
spanischer Kurzurlaub tut doch immer gut
apropos Kurzurlaub wenn du auch mal
wieder Bock hast auf einen kleinen
Urlaub aber nicht weiß wie du dir das
finanzieren sollst habe ich hier
vielleicht einen kleinen Tipp für dich
und zwar kommt da die App hast dann
spiel die für dich ganz entspannt eine
Steuererklärung auch wenn du es noch nie
gemacht hast von natürlich
professionellen Steuerberaterin abgeben
kann das kann sich auf jeden Fall lohnen
und du kannst eine Menge Geld
zurückbekommen deswegen hör gut zu
einfach anmelden ein paar Daten von dir
angeben das geht ziemlich schnell dauert
maximal drei Minuten eine Unterschrift
runter und dann überprüft Zaster für
dich ob du Geld vom Staat zurückbekommen
kannst das ganze dauert drei Tage dann
bekommst du eine Notification von Taster
mit dem Betrag der für dich zur
Erstattung bereit steht du kannst das
ganze akzeptieren oder halt auch nicht
aber ich würde dir empfehlen dass Du
akzeptieren weil dann bekommst halt Geld
wieder und auch erst dann 20 kleine
Gebühr von deinem Betrag ab ist aber
nicht viel also für dich überhaupt kein
Risiko dann auch mit meinem Code den du
auf jeden Fall verwenden solltest Alex
die zehn gibt's noch mal 10 € auf diese
Gebühr also bei Taste anmelden mit
meinem Code würde ich mich freuen hilft
dir sicherlich kurz nach bastelona oder
wo auch immer hin und wir machen jetzt
weiter mit dem Video wir sind auf jeden
Fall auf die Minute genau pünktlich
losgefahren erstmals und sowas ich habe
mich ein bisschen entspannt ich war auch
wirklich der einzige in meinem ganzen
Abteil ich hatte aber echt Hunger da ich
zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon wieder ein
bisschen länger unterwegs war und konnte
mir dann eigentlich über eine App habe
ich zumindest gedacht im Zug zu meinem
Platz Essen bestellen
also muss ich auf jeden Fall mit dem
WiFi verbinden und dann kann man hier
den QR-Code einscannen und kommt dann
eigentlich in das Menü dass man hier
auch Essen bestellen kann aber irgendwie
lädt das nicht ich saß im Zug hatte
Hunger und eigentlich schon im Internet
dass ich mir ganz entspannt mein Essen
einen Platz bringen lassen kann in der
ersten Klasse das war leider nicht so
also ich konnte ein Getränkewunsch
abgeben habe mir dann ein Bierchen
bestellt und das Wasser auch schon
denksticket
also eingetränk ist sogar mit im Preis
drin ich habe zwar auch gedacht ich kann
hier einen Platz was zu Essen bestellen
das geht nicht dafür muss ich selber in
die Cafeteria laufen aber das ist dann
eben so werde ich machen aber ich hätte
auch gedacht man muss das Bezahlen ich
hoffe das Ticket 60 € bezahlt also das
war jetzt nicht teuer normal also
Normalpreis ich bin halt auch nur eine
Stunde und ein bisschen unterwegs 150 km
aber für das Heineken hat sich schon
gewohnt außerdem noch im Preis mit
inklusive waren diese Gummibärchen die
sich dann doch als Nüsse herausgestellt
haben aber die waren lecker so wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe hat es leider
nicht geklappt aber die wirklich sehr
sehr nette Service personalkraft vom Zug
hat mir dann gesagt ich muss einfach ins
Board bis zu gehen da bin ich dann
hinmarschiert so soll übrigens die
zweite Klasse aus und habe dann dort so
ein Sandwich bestellt
mit diesem typisch spanischen Iberico
Schinken das wurde auch frisch
zubereitet hat über 5 Minuten gedauert
und ich habe dazu noch dann so ein
tomatendip und Olivenöl bekommen habe
mir das dann frisch belegt quasi und
gegessen und das Sandwich war wirklich
allererste Sahne also kann man auch hier
mal wieder überhaupt nicht mit Essen im
ICE vergleichen was echt um Längen
schlechter ist leider leider na ja Leben
geht weiter
[Musik]
das hier war dann wirklich auf der
Zugstrecke auch das einzige was ich von
Barcelona gesehen habe weil danach bin
ich im Tunnel gefahren und zack war ich
auch plötzlich schon am Barcelona Songs
Bahnhof der Hauptbahnhof von Barcelona
[Musik]
die Zugfahrt war auf jeden Fall sehr
entspannt weiteres später weil ich muss
mich jetzt ein bisschen beeilen aber wir
sehen uns dann im Hotel wieder nach
einer Stunde und 20 Minuten bin ich dann
auch schon in Barcelona angekommen also
das war jetzt keine lange Reise aber ich
denke ich konnte schon guten ersten
Eindruck sammeln deswegen kommen wir
jetzt wie zum Ende aller meiner zugtest
zur Gesamtbewertung und wir starten mit
Komfort Komfort war okay weiß nicht mega
luxuriös ähnlich wie ein polnischen Zug
den ich auch schon getestet habe also
ich würde zwischen drei und vier
sternenschwanken da ich in Polen aber
auch viel gegeben habe gebe ich hier
auch markiert Essen ich muss wirklich
sagen das Baguette hat mich echt
umgehauen und man kann es überhaupt
nicht mit Zug Essen in Deutschland
vergleichen wir landen hier natürlich
dennoch nicht bei 5 Sternen das wäre
einfach unfair anderen Zügen gegenüber
ja habe ich auch viel von 55 gegeben
Service war auch super mir wurde das
Essen allerdings
wo ich weiß aber stand halt so im
Internet wäre schon ausgegangen deswegen
gebe ich dir einen kleinen Punkt Abzug
vier von fünf weil es ist auf jeden Fall
noch besser als Service möglich aber für
den Preis das heißt habe ich das auch
nicht erwartet naturerlebnisfaktor ja
man fährt durch echt viele Tunnel also
ich hätte mir ein bisschen mehr
gewünscht so näher an der Küste lang zu
fahren aber es geht natürlich nicht habe
viele riesen gesehen sah ähnlich sogar
aus wie in Frankreich noch das merke ich
nicht einmal gesehen und durch Barcelona
bin ich auch nicht wirklich
durchgefahren bzw nur unterirdisch
deswegen hier drei von fünf Sterne und
Preis Leistung ich habe 60 € bezahlt ist
in Ordnung kann man nicht meckern würde
ich viel von fünf Sterne geben ich war
halt auch nicht lange unterwegs und
bevor es wieder einige von euch meckern
es kann sein dass es diesen Zug auf
irgendeiner spanischen Website noch
günstiger geben hätte aber ich kann halt
immer nur die Preise vergleichen wie sie
in Deutschland sind und wie sie dann in
Spanien sind und an die ganz schlauen
von euch ich habe den Zug nicht 4 Monate
vorher gebucht sondern keine Ahnung
einen Tag vorher natürlich ist dann der
Preis ein bisschen höher ich kann mein
Leben nur mal nicht vier Monate
vorausplanen wie anscheinend viele von
euch aber nur Front an dieser Stelle
Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen ich
würde mich über ein Abo freuen für
weitere zu testen und wir sehen uns
nächsten Sonntag wieder gibt's neues
Video hat Leute ciao